le ministre allemand des affaires
étrangères heiko maas est furieux en
cause une lettre envoyée la semaine
dernière par trois sénateurs américains
qui menacent de détruire financièrement
le port allemand 2 à ce mythe sur l'île
de rügen en mer baltique
j'en ai parlé hier lors d'une
conversation téléphonique avec mike
pompéo et lui ai fait part de ma stupeur
et de mon mécontentement
pourquoi ses slips et bien c'est là que
se ravitaillent le navire russe
académique cher ce qui qui posent
actuellement les dernier tronçon
sous-marin du gazoduc qui acheminera le
gaz russe vers l'europe
le fameux projet nord stream ii financé
pour moitié par l'entreprise russe
gazprom l'autre moitié étant prise en
charge par cinq compagnies d'énergie
européenne dont le français angie le
projet de gazoduc north stream 2 devrait
doubler le débit actuel qui est de 55
milliards de mètres cubes de gaz par an
du 'pipeline' north stream entrer en
service en 2011 et qui relie l'allemagne
à la russie en passant par le fond de la
mer baltique et pour les etats-unis cela
signifie perdre en influence dans la
région le gaz russe est beaucoup plus
accessible à l'europe une livraison par
gazoduc c'est quand même beaucoup plus
pratique une livraison de gaz naturel
liquéfié par bateau il est aussi
beaucoup moins cher et comme washington
ne peut globalement pas faire grand
chose
les sanctions économiques entrent en jeu
sauf que l'allemagne a rappelé qu'elle
avait peut-être un peu son mot à dire au
nom de la libre concurrence et que sa
coopération dans le projet nord stream 2
était avant tout commercial business is
business
aussi le sujet a été évoqué lors de la
rencontre de heiko maas avec le ministre
russe des affaires étrangères sergueï
lavrov lors de sa visite à moscou ce
mardi 11 août
la réponse russe ne s'est pas fait
attendre il s'agit encore une fois pour
les états unis d'imposer leur propre
volonté sans aucun recours à la
diplomatie
washington a clairement fait savoir
qu'il ferait tout son possible pour
empêcher le projet nord stream 2 parce
qu'il serait soit disant préoccupée par
l'indépendance énergétique de l'europe
c'est son choix en revanche l'allemagne
a pour sa part fait le choix de
participer au projet je pense qu'elle a
raison
les participants au projet nord stream 2
sont déterminés dans le fait que le
projet sera achevé et il ya toutes les
raisons de croire que cela se produira
dans un avenir proche si berlin
principal bénéficiaire du projet voit
dans le gazoduc russe une source
d'énergie stable
les etats-unis et d'autres pays
européens ukraine pologne et pays baltes
lui reproche de permettre au gaz russe
de contourner l'ukraine ce qui priverait
kiev d'importantes recettes de transit
alors que l'ukraine ait soutenu
politiquement et militairement par
washington à la mi juillet mike pompéo
avait ouvert la voie à des sanctions
plus dures pour empêcher la mise en
service de ce projet donald trump de son
côté a promulgué fin décembre une loi
imposant des sanctions contre les
entreprises associées à la construction
de nord
ym 2 estimant que cet ouvrage allait
accroître la dépendance des européens au
gaz russe et ainsi renforcer l'influencé
de moscou
mais pour l'instant c'est un peu comme
brasser de l'air